you
well hello this is Adam Smith from the
Nobel foundation website in Stockholm is
that Paul Krugman yep congratulations on
the award thank you
quite a time to be awarded the prize for
economic science yes I'm a little by the
way I'm feeling that I don't have time
for this
it's rather bizarre but so the committee
site your new trade theory which you
developed in your papers in 79 and 80
yeah I mean it's really it's a story
about countries that are not very
different in terms of their technology
in terms of their resources but that
nonetheless end up specialising on on
different goods that may be related but
are not quite the same and and do that
to take advantage of the of the
advantages of large-scale production
mm-hmm and the second piece of work that
was cited was was your core periphery
model which seeks to explain why
production is becoming increasingly
concentrated in certain places do you
think that increased urbanization is a
necessary consequence of increase in
globalization not necessarily although
it does work in some circumstances what
what you do get is some understanding of
how we can have gotten to this extremely
unequal distribution of population
across the surface of the world that the
reason why 80 million people live in a
fairly narrow car along the east coast
of the United States is is not that
there's something especially especially
favorable about the geography but it's
simply the agglomeration force
essentially each of those 80 million
people is there because the other 80
million people are also there nicely
book turning to your journalism do you
see that as a natural consequence of
your work in academia this moves towards
a more sort of public outreach of what
you do to some extent it was I mean did
the I always felt that what I do when I
try to explain let's explain the
financial crisis in in 800 words and
what I do I try to model the financial
crisis and and a half thousand equations
are
very much the same kind of effort yes
you are very politically involved now or
at least you take a political stance on
things is that also a necessary
consequence of trying to explain things
um I don't know to some extent but
unless I was I was a very early critic
of the Bush administration because I
believe they were being dishonest it
seemed obvious to me that they were
lying about budgeting arithmetic
so in some sense my economics training
was was playing a role there but you
might use as a columnist for less
controversial than they were a few years
ago not because I've changed but because
a lot of certainly the United States has
come around to my way of thinking so
when I was being critical of Bush and he
had an 80% approval rating there might
have been an enormous firestorm about
about all of this obviously I've got
somewhat beyond the my role as an
economist in the column but hey
economists are people to our citizens to
and have political opinions yes okay
thank you very much from congratulations
again thank you